bonsoir pierre prix auraient merci de
répondre à nos questions en direct sur
arte france
évidemment les chiffres divergent 11 à
12% de grévistes selon le ministère 30 à
40% d'après les syndicats qui croire à
toulouse où vous êtes s'est donné quoi
dans la rue tout à leur écoute et nous
avons pour le second degré constaté un
taux de grévistes de 40%
nous avons procédé à un sondage sur une
cinquantaine d'établissements sur les
400 go kevin est un panel de professeurs
de 1500 personnes donc on est largement
dans les clous pour une fiabilité qui
bien sûr est en fait c'est le sondage
politique donc voilà une autre tout est
tout à fait fiable le rectorat n'a pas
communiqué pas ma connaissance de
chiffres
on avait beaucoup de politiques dans le
cortège parisien véritable soutien sur
vaud ou simple récupération politique
écoutez nous on est dans la situation de
demander que le système éducatif
devienne une vraie priorité dans ce pays
rampante en traitant correctement ses
personnels et en lui donnant les moyens
de fonctionner il faudra bien qu'un jour
ou l'autre une alternative politique
permette de concrétiser de ses
orientations ses aspirations de la
profession qui pour l'instant ce ne
trouvent aucun débouché avec le pouvoir
qui est actuellement en place
on parle beaucoup d'un grenelle des
enseignants un grand rendez-vous du nom
issu de la rue
où se situe votre ministère de tutelle
ministère de l'éducation nationale pour
beaucoup de syndicats ce ne serait pas
suffisant
pourquoi quels sont les points de
désaccord écoutez concernant le gros nez
de l'éducation nous avons fait le
constat avec d'autres d'ailleurs qu'il
s'agissait essentiellement d'une
opération de communication du ministre
j'en veux pour preuve les montants qui
ont été annoncées dans le cadre de la
revalorisation soit disant historique
dont jean michel blanquer reparle en
réalité depuis au moins trois ans il
s'agit pour l'année 2000 à t1 de 400
millions d'euros c'est extrêmement peu
le président macro avait déclaré il ya
un an si on veut revaloriser les
enseignants il faut mettre 10 milliards
sur la table donc ça donne un peu une
idée de la manière dont les négociations
se sont ouvertes dans le cadre de ce
volet pour ce qui concerne notamment
d'organisation de la l'ont quittée voilà
parce que c'est une véritable mascarade
on va demander à des stars à des
personnalités médiatiques de cautionner
une politique qu'en réalité ils ne
verront jamais mise en oeuvre parce
qu'il ne la vivent pas donc on est loin
loin du compte
et encore une fois le ministre phung
fahren en laissant de côté
70 % des enseignants qui n'auront
strictement aucune augmentation de
salaire alors est ce que vous avez prévu
d'amener de nouvelles journées de
mobilisation
écoutez vous savez comme moi que le
contexte c'est un vent complique
énormément les choses c'est d'ailleurs
l'une des raisons pour lesquelles nous
sommes satisfait ce soir de la
participation de nos collègues parce que
c'était pas évident de se mobiliser dans
un contexte où chacun est très inquiet
les suites
elles vont se débattre dans les salles
des professeurs on verra aussi en
fonction de la situation sanitaire des
réponses qu'apporte le ministre comment
on peut les envisagez vous parler du
contexte sanitaire justement parle
beaucoup d'un éventuel troisième
confinement selon vous sir confinement
il y a les écoles doivent-elles restée
ouverte c'est tout le départ du moment
confinement dur sans les écoles
confinement plus souple avec les écoles
war couvre-feu en tout cas pour
l'instant nous sommes en couvre feu
avance à 18 heures et avec mon épouse
nous nous avons fait le constat au
printemps que le confinement dur
alors qu'on n'avait pas d'autre solution
dans les gaines conscient a quand même
produit dans la jeunesse des difficultés
maintenant donc voyons les conséquences
des difficultés d'apprentissage le
connaît une forte à faire depuis la
rentrée de septembre pour remettre les
zélés dans les apprentissages aussi de
combler les retards ils sont d'ailleurs
pas parvenu
l'alternance dans les lycées n'a pas
permis de traiter des programmes qui
étaient par ailleurs extrêmement chargé
nous on est favorable évidemment parce
que les écoles restent ouvertes sur ce
point nous sommes en accord avec le
ministre là nous avons une vraie
divergence c'est sur les moyens qu'il
faut y mettre
ou que la rendre possible aujourd'hui
dans l'académie de toulouse nous avons
quatre établissements du second degré
une dizaine d'écoles du premier degré
qui sont qui sont fermés tout simplement
parce qu'on n'a pas pris les
dispositions nécessaires pour assurer un
protocole sanitaire qui protège les
élèves les professeurs et qui limite la
circulation des virus les jean michel
blanquer a surtout renforcer sa
communication plus que son protocole
justement le protocole sanitaire comment
est ce que vous faites pour le respecter
dans votre établissement chez boîte aux
bains très concrètement dans notre
établissement d'une fonctionnement en
deux niveaux dont les élèves val terme
d'une semaine sur l'autre
là c'est une possibilité qui est offerte
au lycée sur son 10 % des lycées dans le
pays ont d'ailleurs adopté cette
modalité là aujourd'hui le vrai point
noir ce sont les collèges
nous allons des collèges dans l'académie
à plus de 1200 élèves donc en termes de
taille ce sont ces l'équivalent de
l'indicé et simplement le ministre et le
recteur ici sans me faire une
distinction un peu absurde entre deux
établissements de taille comparable au
simple motif qui a un qui s'appelle un
collège et l'autralie c est donc on a
des collèges qui continue à tourner à
plein avec aucune distance à la cantine
avec un grande difficulté à faire
respecter les distances dans les
couloirs pour rien le port du masque
c'est vrai il est bien respectée mais en
euro montrent des situations il ya peu
de gel hydroalcoolique
on est dans l'incapacité réalité de
tracer correctement les gars contact
voilà on a d'ailleurs des désaccords sur
le décompte des élèves qui seront testés
positifs au co vide
justement il va y avoir des tests qui
vont être mis en place par le ministère
de l'éducation nationale dans
dans les établissements des
établissements qui pour certains
fonctionnant en présentiel autres en
distance yale demi-groupe admis groupe
le ministre de l'éducation nationale
monsieur blanc caire a évoquée pourquoi
pas d'instaurer des demies groupe en
collège dès le troisième la quatrième
vous en pensez quoi s'il devait y avoir
un nouveau glissement de ce principe
enfin le voile tant qu on ait la
possibilité de le faire il de ne pas
couper complètement les élèves de
scolarité parce qu'on sait très bien
qu'appartenant on basculera dans un
enseignement à distance va retomber dans
les mêmes problématiques au printemps
mais pas plus près qu'au printemps les
professeurs sont pas plus équipés qu'au
printemps les élèves dont plus personne
ne souhaite que cette situation là après
j'entends bien la nécessité de prendre
des mesures sanitaires mais on pense au
lieu de dire qu'on va permettre au
collège de passer en hybride ou en
alternant les groupes ce que le ministre
a déjà promis en réalité del 11 novembre
il faut le rendre effectif aujourd'hui
merci d'avoir répondu à nos questions
pierre priori je rappelle que vous êtes
secrétaire général snes fsu et
professeur de mathématiques au lycée est
celle à toulouse